i want to start with some of this
written house stuff kyle rittenhouse
appeared with tucker carlson last night
they really talked about a whole range
of issues in cut five rittenhouse
reacted to
joe biden the president whose campaign
had portrayed rittenhouse as a white
supremacist here's what the
freshly acquitted written house had to
say with tucker listen mr president if i
could say one thing to you i would urge
you to go back and watch the trial
and understand the facts before you make
a statement that's not a small thing to
be called that
no it's
it's actual malice defaming my character
for him to say something like that
actual malice is the legal standard for
a defamation lawsuit to succeed in the
case involving a public figure so i
think that phrase actual malice that
didn't come out of nowhere my guess is
kyle's having some conversations with
some lawyers and in fact he said that's
precisely what's happening in cut seven
i have really good lawyers who are
taking care of that right now
so
i'm hoping one day there will be some
there would be accountability for their
actions that they did okay so you're
you're intent on not you're not going to
let that go
like i said really good lawyers are
handling that
so he had some really terrible lawyers
at first including that nut lynn wood
who he revealed treated him horribly and
then he got much better lawyers he has
gotten
not guilty verdicts across the board and
now it sounds like he is entertaining
the idea of defamation lawsuits against
some people jesse your reaction to the
interview last night hunter biden might
have to sell some more paintings because
joe might have to pony up some dough
he's a legit lawsuit he was slandered
with malice
i would add because you can't call
someone a white supremacist with no
evidence
obviously the facts were out there at
the time when biden said that the video
was out when biden said that so that was
reckless disregard for the truth
and defamed this kid who now his defense
lawyer says he's going to probably have
to change his name
and
he's going to arizona state next year
good luck with that you know to some
he'll be a hero
but other people are going to want to
knock his head off so i don't see how he
can go through life after this ever
again it's interesting that a a black
militant
sex offender
with a felonious
record mowed down you know at least 55
white people at a christmas parade
and joe biden said he wanted to make
sure the facts came out before he said
anything yet two days after the incident
in kenosha happened joe biden slandered
kyle rittenhouse as a white supremist
murderer
so
obviously guy you know how the left
rolls if if there's someone that's
innocent
of a certain color that they can exploit
to pursue their radical agenda they will
they don't care about the truth they
care about their plot line but if
something happens that kind of goes
against the grain they'll bury it and
that's why you don't even hear a lot
from joe biden comment or the mainstream
media about the city well they'll just
wisconsin they'll make up a narrative
right the narrative is set in advance
and they'll make up facts quote unquote
to fit it even if it doesn't apply for
example the racial component of the
written house shooting which was just
all white people but they decided it was
racial which is why so many
folks out there including many
journalists apparently believe that
there were black people who were shot i
mean that's how deep the misinformation
runs on this story we talked about it on
the show yesterday in particular and
actually jesse since you brought up the
media
and sort of these these plot lines that
they establish well in advance i have
gotten now two in the last 24 hours two
text messages
from left-leaning friends
who are genuinely
surprised and confused about their
preferred news organizations basically
memory holing what happened already what
happened in waukesha on sunday at the
christmas parade yeah these are these
are left leaning one guy's very left one
guy is i'd say left of center and these
are you know cnn new york times those
types of people and they're saying there
were five people killed there's you know
kids in critical condition dozens of
victims
and it was a huge thing sunday night
with scant details on twitter
and
it is not completely gone but it has
been really pushed away and downplayed
as a national news story now it's kind
of like a local a local curiosity to
these news organizations
and i just had to almost say you sweet
naive children like
i love you guys but this is what they do
if the and i i hate saying this but i
think it's indisputable if
the driver of that suv had been white
or had
been using a gun right a different
weapon different race different
narrative this would be absolutely wall
to wall and we'd be having a massive
national screaming fest
about all sorts of
flaws and systemic racism and all this
stuff and i think people were
chomping at the bit for that and then it
turned out that it didn't quite work the
way they wanted it to and it has been
maybe not fully memory hold but the
level
of coverage has dropped off so obviously
so brazenly so precipitously that even
my left-leaning friends were like wow
this is sort of wild
it would be if you reverse the races a
mass casualty hate crime attack uh at a
christmas parade
and you'd see this perpetrator's face
everywhere you'd see it on magazines
you'd see it on cnn and msnbc the
nightly news would be leading with this
day after day after day
we're not going to see this guy's
mugshot guy we're not going to hear
about his social media post it's
interesting that all of a sudden after
he was arrested his facebook page was
taken down now i highly doubt he had an
iphone inside the the jail
and he deactivated his facebook account
i i highly doubt that he did that it was
done for him and i got some screen grabs
from it and this guy's traffics and
anti-capitalism anti-white anti-police
content i think i saw some anti-semitism
stuff in there there's some wild
conspiracy
anti-semitism hitler garbage
that's chock full of in there you know
it's almost like
someone could
you know create the perfect storm of a a
black supremacist
drug-addled
uh
sex offender at large felony warren out
of nevada got his uh 15-year-old girl
pregnant while he was pimping her at
large
and you can't make this stuff up and
he's out on low bail because some very
low bail
after someone else's girlfriend with
another vehicle so this dopey d.a lets
him out because he's soft on crime and
he wants to empty the prisons and it's
kumbaya time
and and so this guy's just like a
revolving door puts him back out on the
street and now you know women and
children and the elderly uh are being
pieced back together at the hospital
so this is a story that wouldn't go away
for for months
possibly i mean if this was you reverse
the races this would be another january
6th well charlottesville this would be
charlotte's i mean one person was driven
over by a car in charlottesville you
have five dead here 48 injured
and you they've memory hold it as as
you've rightly pointed out
and again it's it's coming from my left
leading friends when it's that
obvious or it's that so flagrant and
blatant that even their own side was
like wow that was a very quick heel turn
they did kind of the same thing on steve
scalise and that shooting right yeah
it's also different it's also similar to
what's happened with written house
because you've seen that people that
watch the trial live because fox aired
it in full and even cnn and msnbc aired
large chunks of it and the people even
my mother and you know people on the
other side of the aisle would say you
know maybe this guy's not the klansmen
the killer klansmen that he was
portrayed this guy seems like he's
genuinely heartbroken over what happened
he broke down emotionally on the stand
and the prosecution's getting their
butts kicked by this judge for
prosecutorial misconduct almost every
single day in the last week of the trial
and then you see him go on tucker
this kid seems open-minded he seems like
he's putting his thoughts together like
he's thought this thing through
um janine said last night on the five
something that really struck me he went
from being a boy to a man
this year
and you look at a kid like this and you
think you know he went there to take
down graffiti he went to kenosha to help
out medically and put some fires out
because you know he worked there his
father lived there he didn't want these
businesses burned down and then he said
you know he supported the
the idea behind the black lives matter
movement he wants
black americans men and women to have
the equal justice that they deserve in
the united states of america and
he he was concerned of the fact that
other black americans that may have been
railroaded by rogue prosecutors without
the means that he had remember he was
able to raise a lot of money and get
some nice lawyers
would have been
just hosed and yeah he talked about up
and thrown away the key and and that was
the kind of really just smart balance
thinking that everybody agrees with you
agree with that i agree with that
everybody agrees with that and it just
has really
shocked the conscious of the country to
see the deceit that's perpetrated
through the mainstream media yeah and
also some of the culture warriors in pop
culture so stephen colbert who's got his
late night show on cbs he did a
monologue and i mean so many of these
shows now are just like
political lectures like you find the
humor in this i i defy you to do so he
came out and talked about the written
house verdict there was some sort of
half-assed booing from the crowd about
the verdict i guess they wanted uh you
know guilty verdicts they didn't get it
because that's not what the facts of the
case would dictate but they're mad about
it because you know it's a tribal thing
at this point and colbert says if this
was legal for him to do what he did then
we have to change the laws and they all
cheered like you know trained seals cut
32 let's listen big news on friday was
that after being accused of crossing
state lines killing two people and
wounding another last year during a
black lives matter protest kyle
rittenhouse was acquitted on all counts
okay
yeah okay cards on the table i'm not a
legal expert so i can't tell you whether
or not kyle rittenhouse broke the law
but i can tell you this if he didn't
break the law
we should change the law
[Applause]
yeah he's not some deep analysis
not a legal expert and there's no way he
watched the trial himself so he doesn't
know what he's talking about gut phone
said something interesting the other day
which he he never does but it piqued my
interest he said you know there a lot of
people on the left like joy say this
thing theoretically well
this if if kyle was black this never
would have happened and i thought to
myself okay let's let's create a
scenario so
black
militants are burning down a
neighborhood let's just say in brooklyn
right they're burning it down they're
burning down cars they're looting their
their their assaulting people store
owners
and
and and a black kyle written house
goes out because one of the small
business owners black small business
owner called them there to protect the
property
and kyle goes out and uh black kyle has
a gun and and and people start and and
black uh protesters start assaulting
black kyle
and the same thing happens that we see
on video
everything is on video perpetrators are
black
black kyle and and black kyle shoots
these people in self-defense and is able
to raise a lot of money to defend
himself and the trial is national and it
and it is streamed and people see it
i would i would bet i would bet ten
thousand dollars that a black kyle
written house defending himself in the
same way against uh black perpetrators
in the same context
would have been found not guilty
and
you and me and every fair-minded person
in the country would have said good
if you are under attack like that
and you have to use self-defense in
order to save your life good we want
self-defense preserved in the court
system in this country so to say that if
kyle was black it never would have gone
that way of course it would have gone
that way and we would have been thrilled
the judicial system would have been able
to see that without
black or white in there just as a pure
self-defense case
as a number of juries have in recent
months yes
with black defendants who use
successfully a self-defense defense and
that's what the jury also saw in
wisconsin look jesse i want to lighten
things up a little bit and talk a bit
about thanksgiving and wish you a very
happy thanksgiving courtesy of msnbc and
giassi ross who has some thoughts about
thanksgiving as we all
prepare to gather and eat with friends
and family let's share this warm moment
together cut 30. instead of bringing
stuffing and biscuits those settlers
brought genocide and violence that
genocide and violence is still on the
menu as state-sponsored violence against
native and black americans is
commonplace and violent private white
supremacy is celebrated and subsidized
from stonechild chiefstick to mike brown
to renee davis to briana taylor to eric
gardner indigenous and black people are
still being murdered by those paid to
protect us from ahmad arbury to trayvon
martin white americans are still killing
native and black americans with no fear
of reprisal
they brought shadow slavery to africans
and native people that still happens
through the prison industrial complex
that imprisons the descendants of
enslaved africans and natives at far
disparate numbers
that is the reality of thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving jesse yeah please
pass the mashed potatoes guys
you